what is going on your burger neck
crunches Mets new now from the get-go I
mentioned to you guys how difficult this
funny fat fit journey was going to be
but it's difficult for different reasons
now there's a few of you out there that
have never worked out in your whole life
like Fitness was not a part of your game
but then there are those of you out
there who used to be really fit and you
go from fit to you know [ __ ] fat or
fashion but one of the most difficult
things that you might have to do when
you start working out is checking your
ego look I've seen it at the gym y'all
seen in the gym you you [ __ ]
know who you want listen to much form of
[ __ ] up trying to do [ __ ] that you
know damn well you should not be doing
but of course when we see it in the gym
you know all of us got to be like but
that ain't about business
cuz we don't want to be that one dude
that says look you're gonna let me help
y'all get all that do this is what you
gots to do it all right all that do that
says but you do is thinking about oh
excuse me
you know if you were if you wouldn't do
it yeah I'm cool doggy ain't harassment
unless I touch you please don't [ __ ] the
cops on me for me this was also a
difficult thing for me not to do as well
the lifting weight thing not not the
butthole touching thing yeah for that
was what the time I was also a part of
team lifts too much but you got to
realize I was guilty of this when I was
a kid that's right when I was a child so
I don't know what else to tell you but
[ __ ] is wrong with you get your life
together
dammit bro nest man look 260 pounds more
than you acts a Chan God dick you know
what you look like huh that's right you
even you made that noise off that knows
you make when you try to lift [ __ ] that
you can't do you think that she cute you
look like a two-year-old baby but just
found out about play-doh for some reason
when you're working on trying to better
yourself you get distracted and trying
to impress everybody in the room well
guess what when it comes to
self-improvement guess whose opinion
matters the most
I take y'all's gun ass you are an
important person you are very special
but you ain't that [ __ ] important
nobody [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] about you
the jam just do you work on yourself now
the workout of the day is a workout that
everybody is very familiar with it's the
bench press ha now before we start as I
always say this I'm I'm here to tell you
how to do it it deforms all [ __ ] up I
am NOT an
I've been trained by other people or I
have been trained by others so if you
want to know more go find out for
somebody else not me
that's it easy now for me I like bends
because why it works out the chesticles
I got these big old floppy titties I'm
trying to morph and sulphide them up and
Soloff is not even worn [ __ ] it it works
out your chest and also your triceps so
the wider you go the more it will hit
your chest the closer it gets the more
harder it becomes on your triceps so if
you got those little wimp flappers you
could always try to do Close Grip
wrenches and you in when I was younger I
used to focus on the bench a lot because
for some reason when you're in high
school apparently having the strongest
chest on earth it's supposed to make you
have a bigger deck I mean but for those
of you who have that bench before as I
say it again please please get taught
how to do it properly because you will
[ __ ] yourself up I actually dislocated
my shoulder once by doing it very
improperly on a bench thing there's
another story [ __ ] stupid I paid for
it whatever but funny fat fit fam
remember as always life is always what
you make it but it's up to you to take
what you deserve
let's go for broke
now at the beginning of this journey I
always meant not at the beginning of
this journey I mean